what's not to get nervous about it's the
most terrifying thing most people do is
talking in public
but remember that the worst that can
happen
is you might be a little bit embarrassed
and it can be fixed later
[Music]
i think the biggest lessons i learned
if you're dealing with bad news get it
out quickly just get it out there
i've interviewed every president foreign
leaders politicians celebrities people
from all walks of life
but i think the lessons i've learned can
apply to all of you in your
conversations with your friends and your
family in your conversations at the
workplace and i'm privileged to have the
chance to share what i've learned with
you
we're gonna take a look back at some of
my most memorable interviews some for
good reason some for bad and i hope that
people will be able to draw lessons that
they can apply to their own lives
how to be both honest and sensitive how
to have hard conversations how to be
confrontational without being a jerk
[Music]
in the workplace nothing is more
important than preparation before
communicating if you don't know what
you're talking about you can't talk
back in 2006 i was interviewing
president george w bush i had the
manifestations of a panic attack i was
in full
flop sweat in front of the president of
the united states i was absolutely
mortified what i learned by making
mistakes is that whatever you're feeling
inside it's probably not as bad as you
think and it's probably not showing as
much as you think you can't have real
conversations without candor and honesty
and that's the heart of all good
communication
i'm george stephanopoulos and this
is masterclass
[Music]
[Music]
you